the Conservative Political Action
Conference known as CPAC was held this
weekend we're going to be looking at a
bunch of different clips from it will
start with clips from Donald Trump
speech and then later we'll get to whole
bunch of other speeches and panels that
took place it'll be sort of up to you to
figure out what's the wackiest of the
entire Gong Show but when we think about
the Trump speech first I want to call
your attention to the fact that in many
ways Donald Trump is becoming more and
more authoritarian obviously there's the
cozying up to other authoritarians and
being hugely impressed by people like
Vladimir Putin and Kim jong-un and
fighting more and more with our allies
like France and Canada and Germany and
we've talked about the attacks on the
media as the enemy of the people
there's the mention that he's made
before of liking the idea of maybe
allowing president-for-life
in the United States the way that China
has moved in the direction of doing
there's the dismissal of all facts and
the creation of completely fact free
narratives that make Trump sort of
authoritarian and I could go on but a
really interesting trait that Trump is
adopting is longer and longer speeches
and this is just a classic authoritarian
move Fidel Castro was known for endless
speeches in Cuba Putin has done
five-hour call-in shows Hugo Chavez and
Venezuela would ramble on and on for
four or five six even eight hours in
some cases and there's a couple
interpretations of why authoritarians do
this one is they genuinely believe that
people are interested in hearing from
them for that long it's sort of like a
narcissism and I think Trump has no
shortage of that another point of view
on long authoritarian speeches is that
it's a way to control the public right
you're not going to get up and leave
during the great leaders speech and it's
a way to exert control over the
population another idea is that when
authoritarians sense that they're in
trouble or that there are threats they
go longer and longer in their speeches
and you could certainly argue that
Donald Trump's presidency is under
threat right now in any case that gets
CPAC over the weekend and Donald Trump
gave a record long speech more than two
hours long and he absolutely lost it in
front of a crowd of total sycophants
first Donald Trump coming out hugging
the American flag which is just this
total sideshow thing that he's done a
few times now
[Applause]
yeah by the way the country music I have
to comment on the country music how dumb
and gullible are you to believe that
Donald Trump a rich guy who grew up in
New York City and wants everything
gold-plated how dumb and gullible do you
have to be to believe that he now likes
country music and identifies it as a
Republican and I'm curious whether
people agree with me
I believe that privately this is a
completely this is a persona Trump knows
is totally bogus
I believe that privately Trump knows
that hugging a flag is stupid but he
also knows enough to realize that the
CPAC audience absolutely loves Trump
hugging a flag and they do they actually
think it's extraordinary and they went
completely bonkers
so then Trump gets into his actual
two-hour speech and he goes after Robert
Moeller in an unhinged tirade Trump
swears in the clip and by the way just
so everybody knows it's okay to air this
this is no one's gonna get fined by the
FCC for airing the president's words
take a listen to this
unfortunately you put the wrong people
in a couple of positions and they leave
people for a long time that shouldn't be
there and all of a sudden they're trying
to take you out with [ __ ] okay
oh man in the crowd just loving the fact
that the president is not going to
kowtow to political correctness he'll
swear if he wants to swear
of course what he's saying makes
absolutely no sense he appointed most of
the people that have been involved in
one way shape or form and saying
everything that's going on in terms of
the investigation is totally aboveboard
and legal and constitutional then Trump
just starts making things up about
immigration and listen to the bizarre
claim he makes about birth control here
but mothers who love their daughters
give them massive amounts of birth
control pills because they know their
daughters are going to be raped on the
way up to our southern border think of
that true story told to me by the Border
Patrol yeah
massive amounts massive amounts of birth
control pills how is he this dumb either
you're taking birth control or you're
not right massive amounts as if taking
more than the prescribed amounts are
effective in some way and then maybe
most cryptically most disturbingly
Donald Trump claimed during this
two-plus hour-long CPAC speech that he
is going to be signing an executive
order requiring colleges to support free
speech what does that even mean
we don't know Trump obviously doesn't
know but it didn't stop him from saying
it now it's that I will be very soon
signing an executive order requiring
colleges and universities to support
free speech if they want federal
research
and that of the crowd suggests everybody
knows what this means but nobody has any
idea what it means Trump doesn't know
what it means what does it mean that he
will sign an executive order requiring
the support of free speech I was
thinking back and actually watched over
the weekend some old CPAC videos there
was a time when CPAC was actually about
conservative ideas there were ideas I
disagreed disagreed with vehemently but
they were ideas that you could argue in
the sort of spirit of the Hegelian
dialectic or of having different views a
sort of yin-yang we need a force that is
for progress and we need a force that
prevents us from going too far too fast
right you could have some sort of more
neutral point of view on the idea of a
party that is for moving forward and
changing everything and a party that
says let's be a little cautious I can
get behind the value of conservatism in
that sense even though I would disagree
with the ideas this is no longer that
okay CPAC is propaganda it's red meat
it's the weaponization of ignorance and
I saw a tweet over the weekend that
really sort of exemplified how we should
be thinking about this this is like
trumpet CPAC for two hours is like a
crazy guy screaming on the subway for
two hours except the guy has access to
nuclear weapons and that's an
extraordinarily scary thought but it's
the reality that's the reality we're
working with and the reality is an
increasingly erratic unhinged
unpredictable but also authoritarian
Donald Trump